Nothing happened, these kids just sent a mean text about me to everyone.
Something major happened. Everyone at school got this text.
And I'm super embarrassed.
I got the text and it was funny. But I didn't forward it.
I know her. And I totally felt bad for her.
It was supposed to be a joke.
I didn't know she'd be so upset.
I really, really messed up.
I'm not a mean kid but, I did a mean thing.
It's no big deal.
This is a huge deal.
I can't believe this happened to me!
This stuff happens all the time.
I could have said something but then, I might have been next.
I didn't know everyone was gonna send it around.
I had no idea this would get so big.
And I don't know how to fix it.
Cyberbullying is personal.
It's embarrassing, and it's hard for kids to talk about.
Many kids don't even realize the role they play.
And they don't always know how to ask for help.
Here's what you can do:...
...join us. Make a promise now to stand up against bullying behavior...
...instead of standing by.
Visit commonsense.org to learn how.